[Musik]
lasst mich euch eine Frage stellen was
ist eigentlich die politische Ideologie
von Vladimir Putin ist er links oder
eher rechts und ich alle schon was viele
von euch jetzt denken oh noch ein Video
über Putin wir haben das ganze Jahr über
von den Barbareien dieses Mannes gehört
was kann man noch über Putin sagen was
wenn ich schon wissen um es deutlich zu
sagen aus ethischer Sicht hat es Putin
verdient aus aller Chester verurteilt zu
werden aber bis vor ein paar Monaten
haben die meisten Analysten seine
strategische Vision anerkannt er mochte
ein schlechter Mensch sein aber kaum
jemand hielt ihn für einen Namen nach
all den Fehltritten die er sich in der
Ukraine geleistet hat ist jedoch nicht
mehr so klar ob er wirklich jeder
geniale Bösewicht ist für die nicht
viele hielten und nach wie vor manche
halten aber genau so wie es davor eine
großer Fehler war Putin zu überschätzen
wäre es heute noch größerer Fehler ihn
zu unterschätzen bzw auf irgendeine
Weise falsch einzuschätzen im Gegenteil
es ist allerhöchste Zeit diesen Mann
endlich alles mythische auszutreiben
denn nur wenn wir in der Lage sind reine
rational an ihn heranzutreten können wir
unvoreingenommene Urteile fällen und
Schlüssel ziehen klare Schlüssel die
heute so wichtig sind wie nie zuvor
genau deshalb knüpfen wir uns heute
Putins Biografie vor und werden in ihr
all jene Stellen identifizieren die sein
bisheriges heutiges und zukünftiges
Handeln erklären ich denke dieses Video
wird eines unserer wichtigsten werden
also passt bitte bis zum Ende gut auf
und schnallt euch vor allem gut an denn
Putins Lebenslauf ist wahrlich nichts
für sagte gemütert unser Fokus wird auf
folgenden Fragen liegen wer ist
eigentlich deine Putin welches
politische Vermächtnis hofft er zu
hinterlassen inwieweit haben seine
Lebens Erfahrungen seine politische
Ideologie beeinflusst und inwieweit kann
man aus diesem Wissen seine bisherigen
und zukünftigen Entscheidungen ableiten
heute werden all diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar natürlich wie so
oft indem wir einen schnellen Blick in
die Geschichte werfen
vom längengrader Hinterhof in den Kreml
seit einer macht erst wenn Putin wie ein
starker Mann wirken einem Macher der in
der kollektiven Vorstellung sogar in der
Lage wäre einen Tiger mit bloßen Händen
zu jagen oder einen Bären in einem Kampf
auf Leben und Tod zu bezwingen aber was
wäre wenn ich euch sagen würde dass der
ehemalige KGB-Agent Putin nicht immer so
stark und imposant war wie er heute
dargestellt wird die Realität
weit davon entfernt war eine Art
russischer James Bond zu sein in
Wirklichkeit war er eine Beamter der in
einem Büro sitzt und hinter seinem
Schreibtisch Meter hohe Akten produziert
er war das Gegenteil jenes klassisches
messianisch auftretenden Politiker als
den wir ihn heute kennen Putin wurde der
wohl kultiviertesten Stadt der gesamten
ehemaligen Sowjetunion geboren in
Leningrad im heutigen St Petersburg in
einer Stadt der Menschen damals noch
immer unter dem traumatischen Eindruck
der 900 täglichen Belagerung durch die
deutsche Wehrmacht im Zweiten Weltkrieg
standen mehr als eine Million Menschen
waren damals verhungert viele Familien
wurden vollständig ausgelöscht auf seine
Mutter Maria wäre in der Stadt fast
verhungert während ihr Mann Wladimir an
der Front kämpfte und nach dem Krieg als
nur einer von vier Überlebenden seiner
ursprünglich 28 manche Einheit
zurückkehrte aber auch als der Schrecken
des Krieges vorbei war hatten die Putins
ein extrem hartes Leben sie mussten so
gut wie rund um die Uhr arbeiten seine
ungelernte Mutter verdingte sich mit
unterschiedlichen Hilfsarbeiten während
sein Vater immerhin in einer Fabrik
schuften konnte dies ermöglichte den
Putin sogar ein Telefon und ein
Fernseher zu haben damals große
Privilegien der Kleine wladimirovic war
während dieser ganzen Zeit jedoch sich
selbst überlassen er hängt im Hof mit
anderen Jungs herum und der Umgang unter
ihnen war nicht gerade von Zärtlichkeit
und Rücksicht geprägt ganz anders als
ein heutiger widersache selensky Sport
einer jüdischen Intellektuellen Familie
im Krieg natürlich ebenfalls schwer
leiden musste wuchs Putin in einer
Arbeiterfamilie auf und musste lernen
sich in einen extrem harten und
gewalttätigen Umfeld zu behaupten er war
quasi ein Straßenkind und für sein Alter
auch noch körperlich klein und schwach
daher wurde er von den schwer
schikaniert und wusste dass wenn er
daraus kommen wollte er sich heraus
kämpfen musste die Frage war nur wie nur
die Antwort lag ziemlich nah und wurde
der damaligen Jugend gerade zuvor die
Nase gehalten in den Filmen und Büchern
die der Teenager Putin damals gerade zu
verschlang war es vor allem der KGB der
als eine allmächtige und unfehlbare
Organisation dargestellt wurde als eine
Organisation die alle möglichen Probleme
lösen konnte KGB Offiziere wurden als
überlegene Männer ja als Übermenschen
gläubtifiziert wie sollte man als
kleines schwaches arbeiten gehen aber
überhaupt in eine solche Elite
Organisation hineinkommen 0 man musste
sich als extrem loyal sehr klugellos und
vor allem gerissen erweisen es ging um
die richtige Haltung Mentalität und
Messerschärfen Verstand ganz genau dies
war der einzige Weg für Putin der in den
KGB führte putin war sich dessen bewusst
und legte sich massig entsorgt schon mit
14 Jahren bewahrt er sich beim KGB ohne
zu wissen dass dieser eigentlich keine
Bewerbungen akzeptierte Namen jedoch den
Ratschlag mit Jura zu studieren und wohl
auch ein paar Kontakte denn während
seiner Schul- und Studienzeit soll sich
Wladimir vladimirovic nicht nur durch
ausgezeichnete Noten für den Dienst
qualifiziert haben sondern auch dadurch
dass er nicht ganz systemkonforme
Mitschüler ausspionierte und verpeste
und zwar nicht etwas an die Lehrer
sondern die direkt an den KGB tja wenn
das kein Zeichen vorbildlichen Charakter
ist und hier kommt einer der wichtigsten
Faktoren in seinem Leben ins Spiel
Potenz Vater war zwar ein überzeugter
Kommunist aber seine Mutter eine tief
religiöse orthodoxe Christian diese Frau
war so deutlich dass sie beschloss ihren
Sohn heimlich kaufen zu lassen sogar
ohne das Wissen des Vaters die Putins
hatten vor der Geburt Vladimir willst du
bereits zwei Kinder verloren deswegen
seine Mutter ihn zu nicht zwanghaft
schützen und hegen wollte sie brachte
ihn selbst das Lesen Schreiben und
Rechnen bei und schickte ihn nicht in
den sowjetischen Kindergarten in dem
Kindern von klein auf die kommunistische
Ideologie von kollektiver Verantwortung
eingeführt wurde das bedeutet seine
Seele ist seit Kindheit gespalten und
das hat Putins Ideologie bis heute
geprägt hört euch mal eines seiner
bekanntesten zitata jeder der das Ende
der Sowjetunion nicht bedauert hat kein
Herz wer sie wiederherstellen will hat
keinen Verstand Wladimir Putin am 20
februar 2000 in seiner Jugend war Punkt
ihr jedoch vor allem eine Patriot der
Sowjetunion und wurde gleich nach
Abschluss eines Jurastudiums 1975 in den
KGB aufgenommen und zwar sogar obwohl
der jünger war als ist das Mindestalter
für die Aufnahme in den Geheimdienst
vorschreibt er hatte sich eben schon
sofort als mustergültiger Schnüffler und
Denunziant erwiesen und an dieser Stelle
beginnt normalerweise der Mythos von
Putin als hätte der Nation der sich für
seine Landsleute und Mütterchen Russland
einsetzt
ich bin mir sicher dass viele von euch
gehört haben dass Putin im sowjetischen
Geheimdienst sehr wichtig war und wir
alle haben uns irgendwann einmal eine
Art kommunistisches Szenario vorgestellt
aber die Realität ist wie so oft weniger
spektakulär in Wirklichkeit ist der
größte Teil der Arbeit eines
spionsbüroarbeit tatsächlich war Putin
alles andere als eine große Nummer aber
hauptsächlich für die mühselige
Rekrutierung von Informanten zuständig
vor allem von Westdeutschen dabei
handelt es sich jedoch zumeist um reine
aktenfresserei und datenbühlerei sich
durch aber tausende einreisedaten von
BRD Bürgern in die ddr-graben und dann
gucken ob sie irgendwo herkommen wo sie
was ausspionieren könnten immerhin wurde
er 1985 auf einem der begehrtesten
Posten im Ausland abkommandiert
allerdings in einem der von den Stories
kontrollierten sozialistischen
Bruderstaaten der DDR die Zeit in
Dresden musste Putin einen Wechsel bei
der Gefühle gewesen sein einerseits
erlebte er die unverbrüchliche Waffen
Freundschaft zwischen KGB und Stasi und
die brüderliche Ergebenheit der
deutschen Kommunisten gegenüber ihren
Herren aus Moskau denn auch wenn seine
Funktion nicht besonders wichtig war
mussten die zahlreichen Huldigungen die
das System ihm vor allem von deutscher
Seite entgegengebracht hat einem
irgendwo sich einen Boost gegeben haben
er legte sich denn auch mächtig ins Zeug
viel durch besonderen Fleiß und Voraus
einen Eifer auf und wurde dann auch
Parteisekretär eine unbezahlte Rolle die
nur jene auf sich nehmen die wirklich
schnell vorankommen wollen tja und dann
brach alles zusammen der Geheimdienst
Offizier Putin wurde Zeuge eines der
bedeutendsten Ereignisse der jüngeren
Geschichte und das auch noch auf der
falschen Seite der Geschichte etwas das
ihn dazu zwang seine Überzeugungen von
allen mächtigen Sowjet Kommunismus zu
überdenken im Jahr 1989 wissen die
Deutschen die Berliner Mauer nieder für
den jungen Putin ein Schlüsselerlebnis
dass ihm gleich aus mehrfacher Sicht
bewegen sollte es ging für ihn ja nicht
nur um den abstrakten Zusammenbruch
seines Weltbildes Demonstranten
marschierten vor dem Dresdner kg Gebäude
auf und wollten es stürmen Putin musste
schnell all die Akten an den er im
mühsamer Kleinarbeit geschuftet hatte
verbrennen all die empfundene
Großartigkeit des russischen dominierten
Sowjet Imperiums und alles wofür wie die
anderen 800.000 engagierten mit Feuer
und Flamme hatte war für die Katz
gewesen eine Schmach die ihn bis heute
umtreibt und deren Vergeltung und
Revision er sich zum obersten Ziel
gesetzt hat die Preisfrage lautete
allerdings mit welchen Mitteln nun Putin
machte ebenfalls in Dresden weitere
prägende Erfahrungen die ihn während
seines Lebens den wegweisen sollten
[Musik]
laut Berichten von Zeitzeugen erzählte
Putin der Demonstranten seine Kollegen
im Gebäude hätten schon die
Maschinengewehre bereit und er würde
nicht zögern den schießgefühl zu
erteilen wenn die Menge nicht davon
ziehen würde scheinbar handelt es sich
um einen Bluff doch er funktioniert
Putin lernte so wie man durchgespielte
Stärke und Entschlossenheit
Menschenmassen einschüchtern kann und
noch ein Schlüsselkonzept hat Putin
während seiner Dresdener Zeit
verinnerlicht das der
verschwörungsgemeinschaft in der nicht
Kompetenz zählt sondern absolute
Realität das oberste Gebot ist egal was
jemand taucht wenn er nicht absolut treu
ist wird er
profitiert wer sich jedoch als
vollkommen ergeben erweist wird
befördert und gefördert das war die DNA
des KGB als Geheimorganisation und das
ist auch die DNA in Putins
Führungszirkel nicht wenige der
ehemaligen KGB-Agenten mit den Putin
gemeinsam in Dresden stationiert war
begleiten heute einflussreiche Position
man kann davon ausgehen dass alle
Personen in Putins engsten Kreis
vollkommen auf seine Linie und auch aus
innerer Überzeugung seiner Auffassung
sind alle anderen hat er nämlich
beseitigt etwaige Spekulationen über die
Chance eines Putsches aus diesem inneren
Zirkel die immer wieder in den
Nachrichten hochkommen sind also nichts
anderes als das Spekulation aber zurück
in die Wendezeit ein Jahr nach dem Fall
der Mauer kehrte Putin gibt demütigt in
seine Heimatstadt zurück nicole
gottschoff hatte gerade das Ende des
Kommunismus verkündet wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt war das alles ein
Schock für die Werte die Putin Jahre
lang beim KGB hochgehalten hatte für die
vielen Ideologie Wechsel des Geheimnis
des gab es nun keine Arbeit mehr deshalb
tut ihr zun uns an die Leningrad der
Universität zurückkehrte und dann
beschloss in die Politik zu gehen als
Lehrer aus den Zusammenbruch des Objekt
Imperiums hatte er ein Bedürfnis nach
unbedingt der Macht und absoluter
Kontrolle mitgenommen vor allem auch
über jede Art von Opposition
zunächst einmal wusste er sich jedoch im
neuen System zurechtfinden und
erforschen wie man es zu Verfolgung
seiner eigenen Agenda am besten
missbrauchen kann eigentlich also ist
ungewöhnliches für ein Politiker er
begann seine Laufbahn als Berater des
ersten demokratisch gewählten
Bürgermeister von St Petersburg Anatoli
Anfang der 90er Jahre war Putin dann
schon Leiter des Komitees für
Außenbeziehung der Stadtverwaltung also
sozusagen der Außenminister der Stadt St
Petersburg seine Hauptaufgabe war es
internationale Investoren für die Stadt
zu finden er war aber auch für die
Erteilung von Exportgenehmigung
zuständig eine potenzielle Goldgrube für
persönliche Bereicherung denn im Ausland
begehrte Rohstoffe ließen sich in den
Trümmern dass sowjetischen
planwirtschaftlich organisieren oder
zeigen Punkt jetzt Aufstieg für macht
begangen genau hier er knüpfte für beide
Seiten einträgliche Beziehungen so nach
Einfluss und reichtumstrebenden
Geschäftswelt und schützt sich ein
Geflecht aus vertrauten einen Business
Unterwelt und Verwaltung seinen ersten
großen
in diesem Fall inspirierte Putin jedoch
nicht die eigene not sein diejener die
ihm eigentlich anvertraut waren indem er
sie schamlos ausnutzte um sich in
gigantischen Maße zu bereichern also wie
lief seine Masche nun nach dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion in der
90er Jahre musste setzt die
Lebensmittelversorgung der russischen
Bevölkerung durch Lieferungen aus dem
Ausland sichergestellt werden aber genau
dieses Programm nutzte Wladimir Putin um
seinen ersten richtig großen Bassen Geld
zu stehen sozusagen das Grundkapital mit
dem er dann seine kometenhaften Aufstieg
bis zum allerhersteller des Landes
finanzierte als Leiter des Komitees für
Außenbeziehungen der Stadtverwaltung
Unterstand Putin das Lebensmittel für
Rohstoffe Programmen
das heißt er kontrollierte alle
Lieferungen und musste diese abzeichnen
es ging um den Export von Rohstoffen im
Wert von über 100 Millionen Dollar im
Austausch gegen Lebensmittel für die
Bürger ST petersburgs die point an der
ganzen Geschichte die Rohstoffe wurden
zwar ins Ausland verschifft aber die
Lebensmittel kann irgendwie nie an und
es gibt absolut wasserdichte Beweise
dafür dass Putin dafür die Verantwortung
trägt das Ergebnis war dass die Menschen
der Stadt ohne Lebensmittel das standen
Putin und seine Clique jedoch 100
Millionen Dollar stattkapital einsacken
konnte 1996 bekam Putins Mentor dann die
Quittung für sein Missmanagement und
verlor die Bürgermeisterwahl wie sich
aber zeigen sollte war dies ausgerechnet
für seinen Wahlkampfmanager Putin keine
Pleite sondern eine günstige Übung im
Kriminal nämlich gerne einige der als
effektiv Geld mit Führungskader aus der
Regel als weltoffenen demokratisch
geltenden Sonntag auf in jedes Moskauer
starb machte Putin und eine steile
Karriere 2 Jahre später 1998 war er
schon einer der vierte Chef der
präsidentialistation und es ging munter
weiter aufwärts noch im gleichen Jahr
aber unscheinbare Ex-Agent des KGB zum
Direktor von dessen wichtigster
Nachfolgeorganisation ist
inlandsgeheimnissesp
[Musik]
in Russland hatte man anders als in der
DDR nach ihrem Untergang oder
Deutschland nach 1945 wenig Energie auf
einem moralische und ideologische
Aufarbeitung des volkeszeit und ihrer
Missstände und Verbrechen verschwendet
vor allem in den Behörden wie dem FSD
fühlte man sich trotz des namenswechsels
noch immer stark in der Tradition der
allmächtigen Kisten wie sich die
Geheimdienstler nach der Uhr KGB aus der
Zeit kurz nach der Oktoberrevolution
hoffentlich noch selber machen
[Musik]
doch Putin bekam im gleichen Jahr 1998
noch eine weitere weit weniger bekannte
ideologische Prägung also was geschah in
diesem Jahr nun es war das Jahr in dem
seine Mutter verloren ihr werdet euch
noch erinnern Putins Mutter war eine
glühende Christel auf ihrem Sterbebett
schenkte sie ihm ein kurzes und wie
Biografen berichten hatte es seitdem nie
wieder abgenommen das war der Moment in
dem Putin seinen Glauben erneuerte und
ihr könnt mir glauben das ist viel
bedeutender als es scheint aber lass uns
später noch mal dazu kommen putis
Blitzkarriere war der belegt dafür dass
er das Vertrauen des kränkelnden und
nicht immer nüchternen Stadtfest Bares
jetzt hin gewonnen hatte und das
bereitet den Weg für Putins macht
Ergreifung nachdem jetzt in mehrmals
seine Regierungschefs ausgetauscht hatte
er nannte er im Sommer 1999 Putin zu
Premierminister und verschiebt auch
nicht dass er in ihm einen geeigneten
Nachfolger für sich selbst sehen
nach dem jetzt in völlig überraschend in
der Silvesternacht 1999 auf 2000
zurückgetreten war wurde Putin gemäß der
Verfassung Interims Präsident und bei
den drei Monate später angesetzten
Neuwahlen wurde er dann auch schon ganz
offiziell Präsident der Russischen
Föderation er gewann die Wahl mit mehr
als 50% stimmen jetzt hatte den Menschen
einen neuen Anführer gegeben den sie
folgen konnten aber ihr fragt euch
vielleicht wie konnte überhaupt ein Mann
die Putin damals eher ein unscheinbarer
grauer apparatschig und auch noch aus
den wenig beliebten Geheimdiensten
stammen damals so schnell populär werden
und zwar die Macht kommen nun dafür gibt
es zwei einfache Gründe erstens das
Versprechen einer besseren
Wirtschaftslage nach dem Kollaps der
Staatsfinanzen im August 1998 und
zweitens seine bewiesen Entschlossenheit
gegenüber den tschetschenischen
Terrorismus vergessen nicht dass der
Tschechien eine extrem turbulentes mit
Unabhängigkeit bestäubungen die in einer
harten militärischen Konfrontation mit
Moskau endeten sollte also der starke
und entschlossene Mann sein den Russland
insgeheim immer
bei ihm zeichnete sich ab dass er die
von vielen in den halbwegs
demokratischen und liberalen aber auch
schrecklich chaotischen Nils 10 Jahren
vermisste harte Hand zur Führung des
Riesenreichs hatte wie wir euch vor
kurzem ein Video über Tschetschenien
erklärt haben hat es Putin damals schon
sehr gut verstanden wie man mit allen
sauberen wie schmutzigen Mittel
militärischen militären und
geheimdienstlichen eine aufsässige
Provinz und sich dabei gleichzeitig
sowohl national als auch international
profilierte das interessierte damals
wirklich niemanden dass er im zweiten
Schienen kriegt die Stadt großen
Erdboden gleich machen liest und 10000
zivile Todesopfer im Kaufland es
interessierte den besten auch nicht dass
ein 1999 als Premierminister seine
fsb-kumpels eine Serie von
Terroranschlägen unter falscher Flagge
inszenieren liest bei diesen kamen 367
unschuldige Menschen ums Leben denn nur
auf diese Weise konnte er überhaupt die
Rechtfertigung dafür schaffen die 1996
beendeten Krieg vorzusetzen und sich als
starker Mann und mache in Szene zu
setzen der besten Putin seine
Gräueltaten durchgehen damit Ihre Hilfe
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen in märz
2000 die Kommunisten schlagen konnte
diese wären beinahe wieder an die Macht
gekommen und putin war einfach das
geringere Übel wie so oft drückte man im
Westen also alle Augen zu um das noch
größere Übel zu verhindern auch als er
anschließend zahlreiche russische
Journalisten und Politiker die diese
Vorgänge untersuchen wollten ließ so wie
auch viele andere seine Kritiker und
Oppositionellen in den folgenden Jahren
wir haben über diese Vorgänge übrigens
ein eigenes Video gedreht mit dem
durchlagen Erfolg seine Strategie im
zweiten Klinik während der Putin das ist
vor allem Hinterlist Mord Terror und
Krieg sind die seine Karriere und macht
einen ordentlichen Post geben können
dies war sein Patentrezept seine
Erfolgsstrategie und diese wiederholte
er dann immer wieder 2008 in Georgien
2014 in der Ukraine und dann eben wieder
2022 es handelt sich im Grunde um die
Wiederholung ein und desselben
Verhaltensmusters natürlich war sich
Putin bewusst dass das Gewalt nicht die
einzige Grundlage seiner Macht sein kann
deswegen versprach er ein Hauch von
Erneuerung im Land aber er war sich
bewusst dass ein großer Teil der
Bevölkerung die so wird Union vermisste
daher sind Maßnahmen wie die
Wiedereinführung der Hymne der UdSSR als
Nationalhymne Russlands mit wenigen
Textänderungen oder die Verwendung der
Flagge der Sowjetunion beim
militärischen Veranstaltungen nicht
überraschend daher kommt es auch das
russische Panzer teilweise mit Sowjet
Flaggen in der Ukraine zu sehen sind
aber jenseits alles Symbolik was hat
Putin wirklich getan woran genau glaubt
er und was treibt ihn eigentlich an
bevor wir diese Schlüsselfragen
beantworten müssen wir euch auf eine
Gefahr hinweisen die von ebenfalls stark
im Verborgenen arbeitenden Akteuren
ausgeht es geht nicht um den KGW oder
FSB sondern um kommerzielle
spionageorganisationen die unser aller
Leben immer stärker beeinflussen und das
ganz ohne gar nicht positiv die Rede ist
von sogenannten data Brokern also das
sind Unternehmen die überall persönliche
Daten über uns und einsammeln zum
Beispiel aus öffentlich zugänglichen
Datenbanken aus unserem serverhalten im
Netz oder wenn man mal dummerweise an
einem Gewinnspiel teilgenommen hat sie
sammeln und verknüpfen diese Daten um
sie denn auszuwerten und an andere
Unternehmen zu verkaufen das können dann
seriöse Firmen sein oder aber auch
Betrüger die uns mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-MAIL formulieren oder
gar ausnehmen wollen das Problem ist
niemand von uns kann wirklich wissen an
wen die data Broker unsere Daten
eigentlich verkaufen wir haben wirklich
0 Kontrolle darüber was wir aber tun
können ist sie zu kontaktieren und sie
aufzufordern unsere Daten bei sich zu
löschen dazu sind sie gemäß verschiedene
rechtliche Regelungen in der EU die USA
und Großbritannien verpflichtet dabei
stoßen wir doch auf ein weiteres Problem
es gibt nämlich tausende dieser data
Broker und sie alle wollen auch
unterschiedliche Weise kontaktiert
werden und manchmal legen Sie die
Anfrage einfach ab zum Beispiel aus
formalen Gründen und man muss sich dann
überlegen wie man darauf überhaupt
reagiert kurz um es handelt sich um eine
süße Fußarbeit aber
ist nicht toll wenn es jemanden geben
würde wäre diese Arbeit übernimmt
herausfindet werden deine Daten hat die
Löschanträge stellt und auf ihre
ablehnungs-e-mails dann antwortet und
wäre es nicht toll das ganze
automatisieren zu können quasi als
Dienstleistung tja jetzt kommt die gute
Nachricht diese Dienstleistung gibt es
und es handelt sich um kein geringeren
als den Sponsor dieses Videos in KODi du
meldest dich einfach bei inkognit an
beauftragt sie in deinem Namen bei den
data Brokern aufzuräumen und schon
geht's los auch eine übersichtlichen
Dashboard kannst du verfolgen bei
welchen data broken sie deine Daten
gefunden haben und wie sie Kontakt mit
Ihnen aufnehmen und wieder
fortschrittlich Anträge ist dann
bekommst du E-Mails von diesen
Unternehmen und in diesen steht wir
haben Ihre Daten gelöscht na ist das
nicht eine Wohltat die traurige Wahrheit
unserer Welt ist nun mal wenn man all
diese löschen Anträge manuell machen
wollte würde dies Monat dauern etwas was
kein normaler Mensch auf sich nehmen
würde und damit rechnen die data Bürger
also haben sich alle damit abgefunden
dass Ihre Daten draußen herumgeistern
und miss verkauft werden ja bis jetzt
schaut euch also bitte unbedingt das
Angebot von inkognit über den Link in
der Beschreibung zu diesem Video an dort
findest du auch den Promo Code
politik.de und wenn du zu den ersten 100
gehörst die nutzen gibt dir in Kombi 20%
Rabatt ist doch nett nicht wahr und
falls Ihr uns etwas Nettes tun wollt
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video findet ihr einen Spenden
Link mit dem ihr uns helfen können
dieses Projekt zu finanzieren so und nun
lasst uns wieder zur Beantwortung
unserer brennenden Fragen zurückkehren
woran genau glaubt Putin wirklich und
was treibt ihn eigentlich an was ist
seine Motivation aufgepasst
wie euch sicher erinnern könnt war Putin
mit dem KGB im kommunistischen Teil
Deutschland stationiert bis die Berliner
Mauer fiel er erlebte die
Unzulänglichkeiten des sowjetischen
inspirierten Systems aus erster Hand
korrupte Beamte und talentierte und
inkompetente Leute die nur für
politische Gefälligkeiten an die Macht
kamen und eine Spirale von Fehlern die
schließlich zum Zusammenbruch des
Regimes führte ja damals hat potent
tatsächlich begriffen dass der
Kommunismus nicht funktioniert
der Kommunismus und die Sowjet Macht
haben Russland nicht zu einem
wohlhabenden Land mit einer sich
dynamisch entwickelnden Gesellschaft und
einem freien Erfolg gemacht für Putin
war ist also klar das ist keine Rückkehr
zum Kommunismus geben würde aber
natürlich war das System
geerbt hatte auch nicht sehr effizient
was glaubt ihr also was er getan hat nur
wenn Ihr treuer Zuschauer von
visualpolitik seid habt ihr es sicher
erraten Staatskapitalismus im Stile
jetzt und wie genau hat er ihn aufgebaut
nur mit Hilfe einer Gruppe von Leuten
viele von euch sicher kennen den Stilo
Wiki wie wir bereits in früheren Videos
erklärt haben sind die Sido
wikipolitiker und hohe Regierungsbeamte
mit langen Karrieren in den diversen
Sicherheitsdiensten des Landes Sergej
evanoff und sergejogo gehören zum
Beispiel dazu und ihr möchte ich einen
interessante Überlegung anstellen für
Putin war das Problem des Kommunismus
nicht das System der zentralisierten
Wirtschaft sondern die schlechten
Manager als jetzigen Übergang zum
Kapitalismus versuchte um gab er sich
mit schlecht ausgebildeten und Teil sehr
billigen Geschäfte machen und
Karrieristen die oft allerlei
Abhängigkeiten Unterlagen manche von
ihnen wurden das was man später als
Oligarchen bezeichnet wird
Wirtschaftskapitäne mit viel Einfluss
und Geld und natürlich einem riesen
großen Ego dafür aber wenig Moral und
zweifelhafter Reputation deshalb
verstanden
Manager durch Leute mit und
erschütterlicher Loyalität starken Ideen
einer festen Hand und einem in seinen
Augen guten Lebenslauf zu ersetzen das
ist das Grundprinzip des Zillow Wiki
Kapitalismus und ihr werdet euch fragen
ob der Kapitalismus im Stile Putins denn
funktioniert hat nun theoretisch könnte
man diesen Eindruck gewinnen schaut euch
mal diese Grafik an
sei Putin im Jahr 2000 an die Macht kam
wuchs die russische Wirtschaft ohne
Unterbrechung bis 2008 tatsächlich haben
sich die russischen Löhne sogar
verdoppelt aber ich bin mir sicher die
meisten von euch wissen bereits warum
denn sowas richtig Russland ist ein
Energielieferant zu einer Zeit als die
Gas und Ölpreise hoch waren erlebte
Russland ein für seine Verhältnisse
goldenes Zeitalter die Wirtschaft
entwickelte sich prächtig und der Staat
schaffte es seine Schulden zu tilgen und
sogar solide Reserven anzurufen hat den
erster Linie jedoch vor allem Glück so
konnte er die Früchte der noch unter
seine vorgängliche Geld ziehen
umgesetzten sehr unpopulären
wirtschaftsverformen selbst einfahren
zwischen 1999 und 2008 wuchs die
russische Wirtschaft im Schnitt um 6,9%
pro Jahr dabei spielte jedoch vor allem
der Ölpreis eine große Rolle der Preis
für ein Barry Brent Öl stieg von 10 $
Anfang 1999 auch über 50 $ im Jahr 2500
erreichte sogar im Sommer 2018 140
$ und die Person die am meisten von
diesen Punkt profitiert hat war wohl nie
jemand anderes als Wladimir Putin
aufgrund des rohstoffbooms und der damit
verbundenen riesigen Geldströme aus dem
Ausland musste Putin
wirtschaftspolitisch nicht mehr
besonders kreativ sein sein
Wirtschaftskonzept beruhte daher auch
darauf gute Manager in
Entscheidungspositionen zu bringen statt
auf der Schöpfung starker Institutionen
die das Land hätten dauerhaft
voranbringen können die
Ära der hohen Rohstoffpreise wurde also
nicht für den Umbau des rückständigen
Landes in einen Rohstoff unabhängigen
modernen Staat mit einer
diversifizierten und konkurrenzfähigen
Wirtschaft mit hoher Wertschöpfung
genutzt nein denn Putins cleptokratische
klicke braucht kein modernes Russland im
Gegenteil nichts fürchte diese
parasitäre rentierklasse mehr als eine
gut ausgebildete leistungsfähige und
patriotische Mittelklasse die ihren
Machtanspruch herausfordern und ihre
schamlose Bereicherung stören würde und
ihr werdet euch sicher fragen was ich
hier eigentlich mit guten Manager meine
ging es ihnen z.B darum dass Russland so
viel Geld wie möglich mit Rohstoffen
verdienen kann dass seine riesige
Rohstoffkonzerne optimal arbeiten und
super profitabel sind an allen
Schaltstellen dieser Konzerne sitzen
anstelle von erfahrenen
wirtschaftsmanagern Putins Hand
verließende Geheimdienstler die nichts
von Betriebswirtschaft verstehen dafür
aber viel von Politik und der Kontrolle
von Machtstrukturen es handelt sich im
Grunde um Agenten die putinsziele im In-
und Ausland durchsetzen sollen und sich
hierzu alle Mittel von
geheimdienstleuten bedienen wie z.B der
Anleitung ausländische Helfer aus
Politik und Medien der beste Beweis
dafür dass Putin den Krieg gegen die
Ukraine und auch gegen Europa
einschließlich Deutschland und lange hat
geplant hat ist in die Tatsache dass das
prom im Sommer 2021 die von der
Regierung Merkel überlassenen deutschen
Gasspeicher nicht jedes Jahr befüllen
ließ
[Musik]
dieses eigentlich völlig ungewöhnliche
Verhalten macht deutlich dass hier ganz
klar die presserische Basis für die
Kriegssituation 2022 gelegt wurde und
waren Putins Erpressungsopfer früher
Länder die Weißrussland oder die Ukraine
so hat er diesmal eindeutig Deutschland
ins Visier seine Gas auch genommen im
Grunde ist genau dieses Verhaltensmuster
der große russische rohstoffflucht der
das Land und seine Nachbarn immer wieder
ins Verderben reist russland hat eine
Menge Ressourcen die andere Länder
brauchen aber der Kremmen hat seine
Rohstoffreichtum lange Zeit dazu genutzt
seinen Kunden geopolitische
Zugeständnisse abzubringen und auch
jetzt ist Russlands Wirtschaft
strategische Politik damit nichts
anderes als eine große historischer Welt
in der Zeit vor dem kalten kriegen jetzt
entweder darum dass Russland seine
Kunden unterwirft oder dass diese in
Russland einfallen so wie zum Beispiel
Hitler Deutschland dann während des
Kalten Kriegs und in der Zeit danach als
ich die Welt für die russischen Exporte
öffnete oder diese Strategie durch den
wett mit anderen Lieferanten zu nichtig
gemacht die Russen glauben bis heute
dass ihre Transsibirische Eisenbahnen
die theoretisch in der Lage ist riesige
Mengen an Güter zwischen Ostasien und
Europa sondern transportieren einer
vorragendes Mittel ist um Amerikas
Vorherrschaft auf den Meeren zu brechen
die Realität sieht aber ganz anders aus
ein einziges großes Containerschiff kann
pro Jahr mehrfach transportieren als
alle Züge der TSR es ist fast schon
grotesk Russland oder potent versucht
nach den Regeln des 19 Jahrhundert zu
spielen und wundert sich dann das ist
damit in 21 Jahrhundert immer wieder
verliert aber Putin kommt aus dieser
denke einfach nicht heraus das Rohstoff
Business wird für ihn auch weiterhin nur
ein Mittel bleiben um seine wahre Agenda
und Ideologie verfolgen zu können die
Errichtung eines großes russischen
Imperiums und dazu gehört in seinen
Augen eben auch die Auslöschung der
Ukraine als Land als Volk und als Kultur
alles andere wird diesen Ziel
untergeordnet und auf dem Weg bedient
man sich natürlich alle erdenklichen
Mittel verwende und Täuschungsmanöver
das erste große Täuschungsmanöver Putins
im internationalen Maßstab war dabei der
psychoq der ihm bereits 2001 im
Deutschen Bundestag gelangen in einer
Rede auf Deutsch wickelt er damals
Politik Medien und die gesamte deutsche
Öffentlichkeit um den Finger in den
Vorgaben das Russland unter ihnen den
Weg der Demokratie der Stabilität des
Friedens und der Annäherung an den
Freiheitlichen besten fortführen ja gar
verstärken werde seitdem wiederholen
nicht nur deutsche Politiker immer
wieder das Mantra Putin sei doch
eigentlich ein lupenreiniger Demokrat
oder aber vor allem nach 2014 er sagt
trotz allem doch ein Weiser einsichtiger
und rationale Herrscher des ideale aber
vom Besten enttäuscht worden sein tja
was aber sind und waren eigentlich
Putins wahre ideale und genau das werden
wir jetzt unter die Lupe nehmen
Europa und Asien vereint
es ist klar man muss nicht Marx lesen um
Putin zu verstehen auch nicht Hajek oder
Adam Smith Putins große intellektuelle
Referenzen sind russische Autoren die im
Westen praktisch unbekannt sind Autoren
wie ivanien jetzt
und Alexander du gehen und das bringt
uns zu einer Ideologie von der
wahrscheinlich nur wenige von euch
gehört haben dem eure Rassismus im
Grunde steht der Rassismus für die
Schaffung eines kulturblocks zwischen
Europa und Asien beziehungsweise als Neo
eurer sitzen muss für eine sich über
Europa und Nordasien erstreckten gegen
Polen zu einem anderen amerikanischen
Block aber natürlich lässt sich das
alles in einem Satz zusammenfassen es
geht um die Wiederherstellung des
einzigen Moskauer macht bereit also das
alten russisch sowjetischen Reis mit all
seinen de facto Kolonien und
Satellitenstaaten für echte eurer sie
hat das alles aber eine viel tiefere
Berechtigung und wie lässt sich diese in
der Politik umsetzen nur schauen wir uns
das mal an
[Musik]
Putin verfolgt eine Art aktualisierte
Version Lina 5 Punkte die der russische
Ministerpräsident Evgeny primarkow 1993
postulierte erstens die Verteidigung der
Position Russlands als Weltmacht und
nicht nur als Regionalmarkt zweitens das
was als rationaler Pragmatismus bekannt
ist drittens die Partnerschaft mit China
als Pfeiler der russischen Außenpolitik
viertens die Ablehnung jeglicher
NATO-Erweiterung und enkelbe Beziehungen
zu den Ländern die gegen die
Vorherrschaft der USA kämpfen wollen und
fünftens das Russland seine nukleare
macht und sein vektorrecht im
UN-Sicherheitsrat nutzt in der
aktualisierten Version von Alexander du
kennst Neuro Rassismus werden drei
bestimmte Länder genannt die Russland
helfen könnten das eurasische Projekt
anzuführen erstens Deutschland um Europa
zu kontrollieren zweitens der Iran und
die Beziehungen im Mittleren Osten zu
stärken und drittens Japan und Asien zu
kontrollieren denn du gehen traut auch
Chinas zukünftigen imperialistischen
Ambitionen nicht so recht über den Weg
so weit zumindest die Theorie ihr fragt
euch jetzt aber warum auch Putin
unbedingt diesen eurasischen Block
bilden will nun dies hat etwas mit der
russischen Urangst zu tun ständig von
seinem Nachbarn bedroht zu sein das
Problem dabei ist diese Urangst
entspringt den ganz natürlichen
geographischen Bedingungen des
russischen Riesenreiches aufgrund seiner
extremen Ausdehnung haben die Russen es
nie geschafft ihr Land konsistent und
flächendeckend urbar zu machen und mit
den Erträgen daraus ein wirklich
funktionierendes und auch
flächendeckende Straßennetz aufzubauen
da ist auch kaum geeignete Wasserwege
gibt mussten und müssen Sie alles über
die Eisenbahn transportieren die doch
kapazitativ recht begrenzt ist dies hat
nicht nur ökologische Folgen sondern ist
fatal für die verlege und meine
Fähigkeit des russischen Militärs diese
hängt einfach nicht Jahre hinter den
eigentlichen verteidigungsanforderungen
der unvorstellbar langen weit und
offenen grenzregierung des Landes
hinterher die einzige wirklich Machbare
Verteidigungsstrategie der Russen ist es
daher sich immer wieder ganz nach vorne
zu positionieren und die dort gegebene
Geographie dann bestmöglich auszunutzen
dies erfordert aber die gezielte
Expansion hin zu den strategischen
Verteidigungspunkten am Meer
strategischen Häfen wie silverstopol
Bergketten Wüsten und so weiter und im
anschließenden Verschließen der
jeweiligen Zugangswege von außen die
Ukraine zum Beispiel hatten das Pech
dass ich genau zwei dieser russischen
strategischen verteidigungspunkte auf
der entgegengesetzten Seite ihres
Territoriums befinden
verteidigungspunkte oder die sich die
Russen einfach nicht sicher fühlen
können das allergrößte Problem ist
jedoch dass dies auch für viele weitere
Orte und Länder in Europa und Asien Geld
die sehr sehr weit von den heutigen
russischen Grenzen entfernt liegen ja
Russland müsste all diese Regionen
beherrschen um sich geographisch sicher
zu fühlen dieses Sicherheitsbedürfnis
der Russen zu befriedigen würde jedoch
bedeuten dass man die Souveränität und
Zukunft von Hunderten von Millionen
Menschen in Ländern wie Island Polen
Tschechien Rumänien der Ukraine Georgien
Kasachstan und und und an den
Ärmel übergeben müsste ganz genau um
sich endgültig sicher zu fühlen müsste
Russland Länder mit mehr als doppelt so
vielen Menschen wie seine eigene
Bevölkerungszahl besetzen und
unterdrücken aus diesem Grund kann man
theoretisch sagen dass die
nato-ost-erweiterung ganz natürlich das
russische Sicherheitsbedürfnis verletzt
und damit eine kriegerische Reaktion
provoziert hat aber dieses
Sicherheitsbedürfnis auch wenn es aus
einem natürlichen geographischen Bedarf
entspringt ist eben vollkommen
unrealistisch da ist diametral in
Konflikte zu den sicherheitsrechten
dutzende anderer Völker die kein
bisschen schwächer sind als die des
russischen außer man geht davon aus dass
die Russen eben irgendwelche Menschen
sind folglich ist die friedliche
Koexistenz eines nationalistischen
Russlands auf der einen und dieser
dutzenden Staaten Europas und zentrale
Asiens auf der anderen Seite aus
geographische verteidigungstechnischer
Sicht langfristig ein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit
[Musik]
und die einzigen Alternativen die sich
aus dieser Tatsache ergeben deren
folgende erstens die Wiederherstellung
eines großen Imperiums als Kolonialmacht
über all diese Völker zweitens das Ende
der Existenz Russlands in seiner
heutigen geographischen Ausdehnung seine
Reduzierung auf sinnvoll zu
verteidigende Räume und drittens
schließlich die Einbindung bzw Einigung
Russland mit seiner jetzigen Geographie
in einem geeignetes Verteidigungsbündnis
[Musik]
dies hätte natürlich die NATO sein
können und es gibt ja diese Anekdote ist
Putin sich am Anfang seiner Amtszeit für
eine Aufnahme Russland in die NATO
interessiert hätte in Brüssel und
Washington sei er jedoch abgeblitzt nun
das Problem war natürlich dass man sich
Deutschland damals bewusst war dass
Russland wieder von einer KGB klicke
übernommen worden war und diese wollte
man eben nicht in die innersten Struktur
der NATO einbinden zu groß wäre die
Gefahr einer verschwörerischen
Unterwanderung gewesen so wie ist die
ehemaligen KGB Leute in Moskau selbst
angestellt haben mein Boot Putin
stattdessen jedoch eine lose bekommen
die strategische Partnerschaft an und
eigentlich wäre es damit werden in
Russland sie wirklich beherzigt hätte
wirklich möglich gewesen dass ewige
unsicherheitsgefühle aus dem endlich zu
beruhigen denn halt aufs Herz ein
Angriff der NATO auf Russland ist schon
eine verdammt weit hergeholte Fantasie
natürlich hätte der Kreml bei einer
Vertiefung der
verteidigungspartnerschaft etwas weniger
eigene spielräumung haben zum Beispiel
auf dem Balkan aber selbst Invasionen
wie die in Georgien und Auslandseinsätze
in Syrien ließ die NATO Russland im
Rahmen dieser Partnerschaft problemlos
durchgehen Putin entschloss sich jedoch
das Jahrhunderte alte
verteidigungsprobleme Russlands anstatt
mit der strategischen Partnerschaft ganz
anders zu lösen denn wir kennen jetzt ja
seine wahre Agenda und Ideologie also
hätte er mit Hilfe der nationalistischen
Ideologen die Bevölkerung gegen die NATO
auf und baute die Illusion einer echten
militärischen und existenziellen
Bedrohung Russland bis sie auf wie
gesagt als ob die NATO Russland jemals
angreifen würde das ist totaler Quatsch
Putin schuf dieses immer gegen ihre
Problem aber um sich selbst als der
große Erlöser präsentieren zu können und
seine angebliche Lösung dieses künstlich
geschaffenen Problems im Rahmen des Neo
eurer Serialismus war die vollkommene
Transformation der jetzigen Weltordnung
die Degradierung des seinen Augen und
minderwertigen bestens es ging um nichts
geringer das heißt darum die Weltpolizei
aus dem Klauen von anderen reißen oder
milde ausgedrückt Putin setzt sich eine
multipolare Weltordnung ein im Gegensatz
zu unangefochtenen Vorherrschaft der
Vereinigten Staaten und um welche Pole
soll es sich dabei handeln nun diese
Pole wären China die Vereinigten Staaten
und Eurasien natürlich unter russischen
Kommando Putin verteidigt das Wesen des
eurosismus dass sich wie folgt
zusammenfassen lässt
Russland sollte den Status einer
Großmacht wieder erlangen und ein
Zentrum der Opposition gegen den
amerikanischen Unilateralismus in der
Weltpolitik werden wie kann Russland
also diesen Status wieder erlangen eine
der sollen des Landes ist natürlich ein
starkes Militär das erklärt die
Modernisierung der Armee die in 2010er
Jahren stattfanden
um eine Hegemonialmacht zu werden
brauchte Russland softpower und damit
wären wir bei der karagano Doktrin
angekommen dieser filmreifer Begriff ist
eines von Putins wichtigsten
Instrumenten um seine Invasionen zu
rechtfertigen im Grunde ist die
Argumentation ganz einfach Russland soll
zum Beschützer aller ethnischen
russischen Menschen werden die in den
umliegenden Ländern leben auch wenn Sie
eine andere Staatsbürgerschaft haben und
auch unabhängig davon ob sie diesen
Schutz überhaupt brauchen oder wollen
das kann sogar bedeuten dass die Bürger
anderer Länder einfach so neue russische
Pässe erhalten jetzt beispielsweise im
letzten Jahren im Don Bass geschah oder
auch in den von Georgien abgespalteten
Teil der Republiken abrasien und
Südosten und auch diese Weise
rechtfertigen die Russen dann das
Eingreifen ihre Armee gemäß diese
Theorie schützen sie doch nur ihre
Landsleute deshalb nennt man das auch
die Landsleute Politik aber ist Putin
damit der perfekte eurasische Führer
Null weit gefehlt in der Politik ist die
Theorie die eine Sache die Praxis eine
ganz andere während des Afghanistan
Krieges erlaubte Putin den Vereinigten
Staaten zum Beispiel Militärstützpunkte
in Zentralasien zu errichten das brachte
ihm jede Menge Kritik von eurasischen
Hardlinern ein doch auch wenn er nicht
der perfekte eurasische Führer ist so
ist er im Moment nun mal der einzige in
der Region sein Ziel ist nach wie vor
die Macht der USA zu beschneiden und
Russlands ihre wiederherzustellen aber
um das zu erreichen muss er nicht nur
andere Samen Schwächen sondern auch eine
eurasische Identität schaffen und wie
hoffen das zu erreichen 0 hört gut zu
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch noch daran wie Pute
nach dem Tod seiner Mutter seinen
orthodoxen Glauben bekräftigt hat nun
dabei handelt es sich nicht nur um eine
Anekdote putinsglaube spielt vermutlich
eine große Rolle dabei wie er die
russische Geschichte interpretiert und
seine Machtübernahme brachte einen
radikalen Wandel in der Art und Weise
wie Religion in Russland behandelt wurde
tatsächlich ist der wichtigste Pfeiler
für die eurasische Identität heute kein
anderer als die orthodoxe Kirche denk
mal einen Moment darüber nach wieso wird
Union war ein atheistischer Staat
Religion wurde verfolgt auch das
orthodoxe Christentum doch obwohl die
Sowjetunion die Religion auf ihrem
Territorium unterdrückte hatte den
Glauben nicht ausgelöscht tatsächlich
sind heute mehr als 70% Bevölkerung in
Russland orthodoxe Christen okay nicht
alle sind unbedingt
aber man fühlt sich dieser
Glaubensgemeinschaft zugehörig deshalb
ist die orthodoxe Kirche ein
Schlüsselfaktor in eurasischen Projekt
Welt andere Länder einmarschieren will
braucht dafür mehr als nur Waffen man
muss nach dem militärischen Sieg auch
eine nationale Identität aufbauen und
dafür ist die Religion von grundlegender
Bedeutung aber wie lässt sich das alles
in der Politik umsetzen
nun eine von Putins ersten Maßnahmen war
als die Steuern für die orthodoxe Kirche
zu senden in Russland sind die Kirschen
von der Steuerpflicht befreit außerdem
gab der Kreml im Jahr 2010 das gesamte
Eigentum zurück dass die Kommunisten den
Kirchen entzogen hatten aber das ist
noch nicht alles Putin hat der Kirche
erlaubte riesige Gewinne mit
Energieunternehmen zu machen all das
bedeutet eine riesige Kapitalspritze für
die orthodoxen Kirchenführer auch
persönlich und nebenbei konnten sie dank
dessen auch noch mehr als 23 neue
Kirchen bauen mit anderen Worten während
der Rest Europas zunehmendes sekular
wird stellt sich Russland in die
entgegengesetzte Richtung aber wir reden
nicht nur über Geld es geht auch um die
Kultur z.B führte er 2012 das Fach
Orthodoxie in allen öffentlichen Schulen
ein und im Jahr 2016
und ausländische Glaubensgemeinschaften
daran hindert großen zu missionieren tja
Religionsfreiheit ist was anderes und
was bekam Putin von der orthodoxen
Kirche im Gegenzug ihr habt es erraten
bedingungslose Unterstützung bei allen
russischen expansionskampagnen als
Russland 2014 die Separatisten im
östlichen Teil der Ukraine im Don was
unterstützte diente die Kirche als
massive Propagandaapparat in allen
orthodoxen Kirchen wurden die Interessen
des Kremls abgesegnet und diese Realität
hält bis heute an
Material ruft die Russen zur geistlichen
Mobilisierung auf der Patriarch der
russische orthodoxen Kirche ist sogar so
weit gegangen zu sagen dass der Krieg
die Seele eines jeden läutern würde der
im Kampf gefallen ist die Kirche ist
sich bewusst dass wenn jemand in
Ausübung seiner militärischen Pflichten
stirbt er sich zweifellos für andere
Opfer dieses Opfer wäscht alle Sünden ab
die ein Mensch begangen hat es handelt
sich um nichts gegen das als die
Ausrufung eines heiligen Kriegs mit
dieser Erklärung wäre es wohl nicht
falsch verstehen Krieg in der Ukraine
aus russischer Sicht als eine Art
Kreuzzug zu bezeichnen doch der Mangel
an freiwilligen unter dem neuen Rekruten
der russischen Armee spricht für eher
geringeren religiösen Eifer vielleicht
sind die Russen doch weniger religiös
als sie offiziell angeben oder sie
zweifeln zumindest an der religiösen
Legitimität eines Patriarchen der wie
Putin eines agent in sowjetischen
Geheimnis KGB war und ist als
Geistlicher irgendwie zum Milliardär
gebracht hat aber zurück von der
softpower zur hardpower die Frage ist
inwieweit gut in eurasischen Traum
konkret politisch verwirklicht
0 bis zum Jahr 2022 hat er erhebliche
Schritte in diese Richtung unternommen
im Jahr 2014 hat er z.B eines der
wichtigsten Projekte des eurosismus aus
der Taufe gehoben die eurasische
Wirtschaftsunion in diese Union sind nur
fünf Länder vertreten Ausland natürlich
sowie Weißrussland Kasachstan und
Armenien letztes Jahr haben wir diese
Union die Auslands Vision der
Europäischen Union sein könnte ein
ganzes Video gewidmet es ging um
Bewegungsfreiheit für Menschen Kapital
und waren zwischen diesen fünf Ländern
aber wo liegt nun das Problem und das
Problem ist dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine all dies in Frage gestellt hat
eines der wichtigsten Länder in dieser
Union ist Kasachstan dass ich immer
weiter von der russischen Umlaufbahn
entfernt aber auch darüber haben wir in
anderen Videos schon ausführlich
gesprochen fakt ist entschlossener
Schritt zu Verwirklichung seine
eurasischen Träume war eben auch die
Invasion der Ukraine am 24 Februar 2020
[Musik]
dank dieses Schrittes steht er nun
jedoch vor einem Scherbenhaufen seines
Lebenswerks was ihn im Detail dazu
getrieben hat welche Annahmen dem
zugrunde lagen und wie sich Putin und
seine Berater dabei verkalkuliert und
verrannt haben darüber haben wir seitdem
schon viele Videos gemacht schaut sie
euch in der videoliste ruhig mal an wenn
ich denke dass sie heute aktueller sind
denn je und die wäre es wenn ihr mal
allgemein unsere alten Videos Analysen
und Vorhersagen unter die Lupe nehmen
und uns dann in die dortigen Kommentare
oder auch hier schreibt was ihr darüber
denkt wie gut sind unsere Aussagen
gealtert haben sie sich als wahr
erwiesen oder nicht vergleicht uns doch
ruhig auch mal mit anderen Analysten
oder Youtuber die die es gerne wären und
zieht dann Bilanz bei Ihnen und bei uns
und bleibt an dieser Stelle nur noch
Putins Lebenswerk abschließen zu
bilanzieren um euch damit auch einen
Ausblick in die Zukunft zu gehen welche
Erfahrungen spielen in der Genese des
heutigen Vladimir Putin also die größte
Rolle womit ist der immer wieder
vorangekommen was hatte ihm gut
funktioniert nun es waren von Anfang an
Eigenschaften wie Loyalität und
Verschwörung auf der einen Seite
Misstrauen Paranoia Täuschung Verrat und
fallen schnellerei auf der anderen dann
massive Korruption und systematische
Bereicherung und schließlich Terror Mord
und Krieg diese Mittel waren immer das
Handwerkszeug mit dem Putin den größten
Erfolg hatte daher wird es sie immer
wieder anwenden er kommt aus diesem
Verhaltensmustern selbst nicht mehr
heraus auch wenn sie im Falle der
überall in Russland auch auf den
obersten Führungsebenen kassierenden
Korruption den erreichen seine
eigentlichen Ziele heute im Wege stehen
wenn die Kultur der Korruption in Putin
selbst nicht so verinnerlicht wäre hätte
er sie vielleicht bekämpft und dann wäre
nicht nur die russische Armee in einem
viel besten Zustand nein er hätte von
seinem Geheimnis auch bessere
Informationen über den Zustand der
ukrainische Streitkräfte erhalten
Informationen die in von einer bereits
angelegten Version eventuell hätten
zurückschrecken lassen das gleiche gilt
für seinen inneren Zirkel hätte er ihn
nicht vollkommen von kritikernen
bereinigt während seine Entscheidungen
wohl etwas was ausgewogener und
fundierter hätte er nicht auf das Mittel
Krieg zu erreichen seines eurasischen
traumsgesetz hätte sich Russland für
seine Nachbarn nicht zu einem absoluten
Albtraum entwickelt vor dem man in die
NATO flüchten muss und hätte er
Rohstoffe nicht als Erpressungsmittel
genutzt wäre Europa noch immer der beste
Kunde Russlands
aber wie gesagt darum ging es ihm
sowieso nie wirklich aufgrund der neuen
Reaktion des Westens auf seinen Invasion
der Film und das 2014 rechnete er damit
auch mit einer Zerschlagung der ganzen
Ukraine durchzukommen und wenn die
Ukraine gefallen wäre hätte Putin als
nächstes getestet ob die NATO wirklich
zusammenhalten und die Bündnisfall
ausrufen würde wenn er noch ein wenig
weiter nach Westen geht schließlich hat
er sich darauf verlassen in vielen
europäischen Ländern genügend spaltpilze
ausgesprochen zu haben die das
Verteidigungsbündnis auseinandertreiben
und wer und ich machen würden sowohl bei
seinem Angriff auf die Ukraine als auch
später auf das Baltikum Polen und
weitere Länder die gemäß einer Ideologie
heim ins große russische reich geworden
in Ungarn und Deutschland gelang ihm das
auch sehr gut aber zum Glück erwiesen
sich seine Raketen im Rest Europas als
nicht mächtig genug und vor allem die
europäische Öffentlichkeit nahm ist
nicht mehr hin dass sie schon wieder
eine mörderische Diktator auf ihrem
Kontinent breit machen will ohne dass
ihre Politiker im wirksam stoppen wollen
Biografie Putins ist also die Geschichte
eines Mannes der mit seinen Werten und
Eigenschaften zwar eine Russland
aufsteigen und seine Macht auf
unabsehbare Zeit festigen konnte darüber
hinaus sie doch weitestgehend mit seiner
Agenda gescheitert ist dazu zumindest
jede Teile der Welt die heute den Ton
angeben eben doch anders ticken als das
Umfeld in dem er groß geworden ist und
das einen Charakter geprägt hat das
Handwerkszeug dass er sich im Laufe
seines Lebens angeeignet hat
funktioniert eben nicht den Rest der
Welt es ist jedoch davon auszugehen dass
ihnen Rückschläge und Misserfolge nicht
davon abhalten werden sein Verhalten
oder seine langfristige Agenda
grundsätzlich zu ändern Russland wird
unter Putin immer gefährlich bleiben und
der einzige Weg für Frieden in Europa
ist entweder ein Regimewechsel oder eine
derartige militärische Schwächung des
Adressaten das hat keinen Schaden der
anrichten kann beide Dinge werden ein
sehr langen zeitlichen Horizont
erfordern aber letzte das kann immerhin
beschleunigt werden indem die Ukraine
die Mittel erhält um Russland
militärisch zu schlagen so und nun
hätten wir für euch noch ein paar Fragen
über die gerne in den Kommentaren
philosophieren können wird der Krieg in
der Ukraine der Todesstoß für Putin
eurasisches Projekt sein oder könnte es
doch noch einen Auftrieb erleben wenn er
den Krieg gewinnen sollte werden sich
seine eurasischen Partner nicht für
immer enttäuscht verraten und
eingeschüchtert fühlen wie immer sind
auch eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat abonniert
habt falls ja gebt uns bitte dann leid
aber keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]